real happy good yeah your energy is good
yeah he's amazing your eyes are good
yeah like puffy Chinese eyes I can't
believe you think in Asian food I love
puffy Chinese I told him let's do the
whole podcast eating Korean barbecue I'd
be great and you wouldn't even if I can
spring for it
well story man 5 4 3 2 1 oh god man I
[ __ ] woke up like 10 15 minutes ago
in such a bad mood it's such a bad lie
cuz I was in Canada puffy Chinese eyes
this guy has the kind of Chinese eyes
right yeah when they're like on a train
in China
I don't know how they're compacted and
they get so stressed out that their eyes
bulge out a little bit yeah that's what
he has right there again an hour for no
reason you know that's what that I and
there everyone's close together like
this and their eyes get puffy and for
the audio it's where he's talking about
a white guy
there's a white cupcake I will just let
you guys know that Eric Stonestreet is
in the [ __ ] room yeah but I haven't
introduced him yet yeah which is making
a very uncommon I don't care but that's
how I do it that's the way it's done in
life well technically the rule is once
you say his name he's allowed to talk
and he said my name that's that's your
rule you should I won't talk about your
eyes yeah and he's got Andre Agassi's
haircut oh so pretty cool so the Chinese
stress eyes Andre Agassi haircut right
and you have a nice body former baseball
player yeah play baseball
but anyway um you're giving me a hard
time you know because um somebody was
parked in a spot I couldn't get my truck
in in your garage
your gate sucks then I had to walk
through some other people's patio to get
up to your apartment that smelled like
dog urine okay
all this can be handled if you just like
had a normal place for it like real
podcasters I know but that's why I
purchased a little tiny townhouse
oh it's a no no no it's a house oh it's
a nice house cuz you sold it as a house
off air and then if you were just about
to tell me compared to your house in the
townhouse yeah well this is it true that
you bought I mean I this is because I've
talked to somebody I just want to know
you bought the house next to yours and
combined it them mm-hmm combined it you
don't really conjugate like that it's
just combined you combined it did it
know that you don't have to get twice an
American citizen right who told you I
bought the house next to me who stole I
don't remember who said that but I
remember it is saying it here say and
then me saying it like out like yet he
could do where he wants or they did it
was it presented in a way like yeah yeah
near the area connecting all the houses
he just takes a whole like block were
like good homes but I remember when you
lived in a one-bedroom for apartment you
know in Studio City Burbank
okay whatever you know right the valley
yeah and I want to say this but I'm
gonna buck it I'm gonna get emotional
god you're laugh don't do that again
okay I'm [ __ ] tire your [ __ ] okay
your attitude your head is getting way
too big he was really short with me in
the garage I said is this your car and
he said no and I was like okay
[ __ ] I love you you always welcome yeah
I didn't know what I was saying right
now cuz I got so you were talking about
getting emotional about my one-bedroom
apartment all ways you know you know
I'll be I'll be honest you've always
been just the nicest guy your voice do
you have a change they don't think I
don't think I am I don't think you have
either I think that you're you've always
stayed the same
I mean that's why you can come here to
do this you know because I asked you to
do this by the way because people let me
tell you let me tell you something and I
gonna talk before we started just
because I didn't I didn't want to do a
redo we were you won't allow us to do a
redo and tell stories that we told
before because the reason I'm saying
that is I was bet on Howard Stern a lot
of people comment about my interview
with Howard Stern but the tiger belly
podcast is up there with fan love of my
podcast radio appearances truth yeah
yeah and I believe thank you so you must
have liked more than mommy and dad list
their like you must have real people
this thing no we know aren't we I think
we're a but you know it's reinvented in
my career I think your career never
needed to be reinvented saved there was
a reversal waiting that why I like you
know very good to shame I've learned
that in the class right you know you get
them kid in Game of Thrones remember he
was pinned up against the wall with all
the arms or on oh that's me yeah and
you're you're like you know me I'm
behind you and I open my eyes and they
use you know fire but no you're
seriously like I get a ton of comments I
just told you before I yeah we started
that somebody just literally said hey
when are you going back on Tiger belly
and I'm like oddly next week yeah it's
um you know she did it my girlfriend did
made me do this do the podcast yeah
because she's awesome he's awesome and
you set up with awesome like okay now
I'm engaged
so the battery I needed but I had heard
him on so many different other people's
podcasts and I think he's audio gold I'm
like why are you doing this yourself it
you are good dude I mean you know I've
never listened to what other than my own
my parents but you are
[Music]